Yeah my name's Jason.
Right now I'm living in San Antonio, TX.
I was in the military for 31 years, and now I'm retired.
Chris Hogan here.  I've spent a lot of time on the road speaking with people about their millionaire success stories.
Whether I'm at an event talking with someone focused on a plan, or talking on my podcast about self-made millionaires...
one thing is very clear.  Most people have no idea
what the average millionaire looks like.
You're about to step into the life of someone who crossed over to millionaire status on their own terms.
It's the result of compound discipline over time.
So here we go people.  It's the next episode of Millionaire.
Jason is in San Antonio.  Hey Jason!  How are you?
Doing good.  How are you sir?
Better than I deserve.  What is your net worth sir?
Two million dollars.
Two million dollars.  Very cool.
So in the beginning, growing up I guess very early I learned about hard work.
And my Dad taught me about harder hard work.
He also taught me about how to save.  How to save money.
Learned a little bit about compound interest at a very young age.
So with that I really didn't even start to save until I was 25 years of age.
And that was after I had a college degree.
But before that, going through college I never went into any type of debt because I had a reserve office training course scholarship, ROTC scholarship.
I had that and eventually I decided to make my career in the military.
I initially when I started I was a field artillery.
Field artillery is putting rounds down range, putting big bombs down range.
And I started out making I would say like $25,000, $30,000.
I never, even in my highest years, I never went above about $130,000.
So on average I was going $60-80,000/year.
Yeah, I think that anybody can become a millionaire and it doesn't matter if you're making $30,000 or $50,000/year.
And I think the key just for me, for us, is just living below your means...
Just like you would get on a diet or just like you would say I wanna quit my cokes and I wanna go to water.
I mean it's, or it's just whatever you wanna do, it's just a change of behavior,
and so I think that's the more difficult part
and you can get there.
On post you have folks in finance.
You've got a financial support center on all major posts
where you can go to and talk to them, counselors
So if you have questions about, "how do I get a thrift savings plan?"
Or "Should I buy this car?"
You're gonna have folks that can counsel you and talk to you.
Uh, there's other opportunities, but the military community can be deployed to invest.
If you're deployed, you're gonna make more money, and there are opportunities where you can invest in the thrift savings plan tax exempt.
And above and beyond what you normally would be able to participate in if you were not deployed.
What you do is you just got to start, quickly as you can.
If you can only start now, start now.
Cause you don't want to procrastinate it because the earlier you do it, the more time is on your side
to become the millionaire.  And actually the earlier you do it the least amount you have to save to become a millionaire.
If you can just start now, and if it's only $25/month that you can afford or $50/month
Go ahead and do that. And the best thing to do is just put it into an automatic investment plan and don't worry about the market.
Cause the markets, they go up and down.  But over time they always go up.
And they did for me as well.
And you're going to hear things on the news about this or that
And you just sort of have to stay with it.
If I can teach my daughter or other folks to do it
What'll happen is by living the example of being a millionaire, or showing compound interest or
showing that you can save a little and that you can do this, they're gonna do the same thing to their kids
and then you'll just create other folks who live the life of millionaires.
When I went through high school,
I didn't graduate in the top 10.
I can tell you exactly where I graduated.
I was in the 37th percentile.  And this was a school from South Carolina
And I didn't really learn how to write and read too well until I was in college.
And so I had to struggle in college, but I am no genius at all.
And if I can do it, I guarantee you - you can do it.
Don't miss that.  Hard work, dedication, and following a plan
will take you where you wanna go.
I want you to get so excited, you can't sleep.
It's time to get busy people because you got stuff to do.
And guess what?
I've got more ideas, inspiration, and action steps for you.
Check out my podcast, Retire Inspired